Proliferation of nuclear weapons is a
detestable artifact of human beings,
seemingly ineradicable desire to
dominate other human beings.
Nuclear weapons,
perhaps more than any other manmade
thing,
represent that uneasy dichotomy between
the brilliant scientific creativity of a
technological achievement and the
consequences of its function,
its attention that's been explored by so
many thinkers and moralists even by some
of the scientists who work themselves on
the famous or infamous Manhattan.
The only reaction I remember perhaps I
was blinded by my own reaction,
was very considerable elation and
excitement and I was going to parties
and people got drunk and it would make a
tremendous interesting contrast what was
going on in Los Alamos at the same time
as what was going on in Hiroshima.
Nuclear weapons have been tested over
2000 times since little boy and fat men
were dropped on Nagasaki and Hiroshima
for tests and demonstrations for civil
engineering purposes,
moving land,
creating artificial bays,
things like that.
There was even an extended US military
operation called operation.
Plowshare started in 1958 at the height
of the atomic age,
which aim to exploit the quote,
friendly Adam.
Plowshare saw the explosion of 35
nuclear bombs until public outcry shut
the program down in 1975.
The nuclear industry wanted to
desensitize the public to the negative
connotations associated with nuclear
weapons,
but the problem was that those negative
connotations were present in every step
of the program.
Project GNOME vented radioactive steam
over the very press gallery that was
called to confirm it safety.
The next blast,
104 kiloton detonation at UCO.
Flat Nevada displays 12 million tons of
soil and resulted in a radioactive dust
cloud that rose 12,000
feet and plume toward the Mississippi
River.
You can read all about operation plow
share in the Department of Energy's
executive summary of the program,
which I'll put in the description below.
Even now,
they seem to talk about it with a kind
of what could have been disappointed.
Plowshare and the hundreds of other
nuclear tests that have been done since
its termination deal in the super
violent production of fundamental
particles that have a real,
almost unbelievable impact on
environmental makeup.
Indeed,
the creation of new chemical elements
like Einsteinian from and were the
result of the first thermo nuclear
explosion code named Ivy Mike in
Nineteen 52 nuclear blast create so much
change in the environment that their
fingerprint can be felt in fields.
On the opposite end of the academic
spectrum,
in 2008 occurred to Russian avant garde
painting expert Alaina Baster,
then curator of the Russian museum in St
Petersburg inundated with a booming
forgery market that have scientists
chemically tested the paint in
suspicious canvases.
They might find something in its makeup
which dated the pieces more accurately
than other methods using a mass
spectrometer basner and some
artistically minded scientists were able
to see that to isotope caesium 1:37
and strontium 90 appeared in greater
concentration in canvases from after
1945 when the first nuclear weapons were
detonated.
These radioactive vision products are
ejected from nuclear blast into the
atmosphere and absorbed into earth,
soil,
and then Earth's plant life,
namely flax plants from which we get
flaxseed oil or linseed oil,
a major bonding agent and oil paints.
This fills me with such an odd feeling.
Almost all post 1945 oil paintings
contain a fingerprint of nuclear
weapons.
Remember that next time you go to your
local gallery or if ever you lose faith
in the ironic interconnectedness of all
things that within our most refined
creative impulse lurks traces of are
equally refined,
exact opposite impulse for destruction.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
There are so many tangents I could have
gone down with this video and I want it
to.
I just didn't want to make it too long,
but I put a lot of the links and sources
in the description under works cited so
you can read for yourself some of the
cool stuff about operation cloudshare
about nuclear weapons,
fishing products,
art forgeries.
There's just a lot of cool things.
Thank you to everybody who followed me
on Tumbler and used the ask me anything
feature to have some discussions about
some cool stuff about this video,
but other videos I encourage you to keep
doing that.
Tumbler is really cool for,
for doing sort of longer discussions
about things and I'll see you next week.